si on laisse de hawaï oui effectivement
il faut absolument qu'on avait dans ce
sont david à ardon mec moi moi les bras
m'en tombent
oui c'est compliqué où il ya des
conflits difficiles pour certains
cependant moi par exemple au confinement
est certainement beaucoup plus facile
qu'on peut donc beaucoup de gens je peux
je peux l'entendre fait le concevoir
mais ce qu'il faut c'est pas super
league aarau
ce kit ans elle n'est pas un compliment
difficile pardon alors et il fallait les
bras vous en tombent un vraiment tombe
bien c'est sophie koch non mais c'est
vrai que quand on l'entend dire assez
c'est très difficile le confinement dans
ce quartier là c'est le quartier plus
cher de paris à montbard là où les
loyers sont les plus élevés donc je vois
pas très bien en quoi
et puis c'est son rôle de chien s'en
fout c'est pas grave c'est pas le
problème c'est pas le sujet c'est son
rôle d'adjoint à la mairie de paris de
re cadres et de remettre absolument les
choses en perspective c'est exactement
ce que disent et gilles tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que les français vont se
mettre dans le crâne que le 11 mai il ya
peu de virus or c'est faux
j'espère véritablement que demain à 15h
l'annoncent d'une déconfinement va
resserrer les boulons et recadrer
absolument la manière dont la population
devra se comporter à partir du 11 mai
j'espère jean michel maire et après je
vais voir et me faut dire aussi que les
chaînes d'info en général aux leurs
parce que dans cette période anxiogène
tous les soirs on montre la nouvelle
convivialité car entre voisins et si à
qui mieux mieux la contrebasse et son
bail pour lui c'est sympa mais du coup
il ya une surenchère et chacun voir son
image un peu et c'est celui qui fait le
plus de buzz sur son balcon et
maintenant les gens qui font les dj sont
remplies alors nous rejoignent et
emmanuelle grégoire donc l'adjoint à la
mairie a minimisé donc ces vidéos qu'on
a pu voir dans le 18ème arrondissement
on va en voir les vidéos pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent regardez la vidéo de ce
qui s'est passé ce week-end
il a minimisé et donc ne ne produira
juste regarder revoyez la vidéo regardez
compléter la remontée
rires
[Musique]
week-end en missionnaire je suis désolé
mais il est très sympathique ce jeune
homme est le premier à se laisser le dj
la rue en pleine confiance et pas une
boîte de nuit la rue savary il le dit
tiens oui ça m'a un petit peu d'ambiance
suis désolé c'est pas pour ça qu'il ne
descende pas en bas raymond vraiment
pensé vraiment celle des gens qui sont
passés par hasard moi je suis rejoint
jean michel le mec c'est pas la première
fois qu'il faisait ça il a refait déjà
depuis une semaine il met ma musique
dérange aussi d'autres voisins un musée
qui lui ont laissé faire maintenant il
s'est passé ça moi je dis vraiment le
mec là le conseiller ne sais pas quoi de
la mairie là n'a pas à minimiser sa au
maire adjoint au maire et l'adjoint au
maire ya plein de gens on est enfermés
chez nous on fait l'effort de rester
chez nous pour mémoriser des gens qui
dansent sur dalida et une fois de plus
si c'est arrivé ailleurs je m'en fous je
le répète si c'était encore des gens de
banlieue où je sais pas où à barbès on
aura dit regardez ils respectent orient
ces gens là là c'est là aussi non
respectés rire quand y'a un p'tit vieux
donc non dans une rude dans le lubéron
qui se paraient que par les gendarmes
parce qu'il avec son petit-fils main
dans la main pour lui mais 135 euros
alors qu'il est dans la formule aidant
ils gênent personne le mec et on lui met
135 euros
et là les mecs ils ont rien fait dont on
peut pas envoyer ce message là de dire
vous pouvez leur retire il ya quelqu'un
qui lit baba on t'aime elodie elodie que
j'embrasse ma chérie qui dit non
messieurs emmanuel grégoire pense qu'à
se protéger pour ce deuxième tour honte
à lui de défendre tous ces individus
responsables
alors voilà l'homme l'homme et la femme
attention cependant la normale j'ai
zappé j'ai zappé sur s'est vite je
pensais être tombé sur les simpson en
voyant sophie cost bravo très drôle les
bobos parisiens je supporte pas assez
alex qui nous disent ah c'est vrai que
les bobos parisiens reste c'est vraiment
une année riche en train d'aller faire
des footings
ils ont droit d'aller dans les parc des
buttes chaumont ils ont tous les droits
et en droit de faire ce qu'ils veulent
eux ils sont immortels non ces chiens
rester chez nous on travaille pas on
perd de lozère on attend comme des coûts
que des compliments pour retourner vos
scènes et d'en valider bayrou farce
outre écoulé alors il ya maintenant je
vais c'est moi qu'on attend